he had a yet an incident that was public
on uh peds where
you got uh dope tested and didn't pass
um i watched an interview with that and
you were talking about how you really
didn't know what the hell you were doing
at the time
just didn't dose it right or you just
kind of like you know took a stab at it
for yourself the interesting thing
though is that
i've noticed with testosterone is it
doesn't make that much of a difference
you know as you get older like when i
was 25
i could i could easily bench press three
plates like now it's like two plates you
know if i'm lucky and i'm on trt right
so it's not like it makes a huge
difference but
like how far over the limit did you test
like was it just marginal like
when it ended up happening so
i like i i wasn't successful with it
because
my strategy was what i heard that
other people were doing but i didn't
have all the pieces
is you would replace your normal
testosterone levels with synthetic
testosterone so
you do 100 to 150 milliliters per week
um which is about half of what a normal
doctor's prescription is for it
but the idea is that your levels are
going to be the same but
the synthetic testosterone is better
than the natural testosterone and
i don't know i believe that yeah
i mean i was stronger when i was in my
20s natural than what i am today
yeah so i don't know if that's true or
not that was that's just the line of
thinking that's the theory though
yeah this was the theory behind it so if
you keep it that the
um the commissions when you're tested
they
tested it was it just straight t like
scipione
or ethynate or was it like d ball
because d ball can make you strong
testosterone
okay um and it was uh
yeah so um
oh yeah so the the ratio so you can test
three to one or four to one
at the time in certain commissions for
your testosterone to estrogen ratios
right
which is your normal human is one to one
usually anyway so
it gives you a pretty good range to be
on that synthetic
as long as you're within that range you
pass and
you're fine but i didn't know what i was
doing so you're supposed to come off of
the
injections like three weeks prior and
then you're supposed to use a topical
i guess well i didn't have a topical and
i didn't know and i use injections until
like a week out so i i my ratios came
back nine to one so after they did that
i was flagged and then they tested for
synthetics
so extra money to see if it was
synthetic and it was
so i got like devil's dummy little
double way made
but that was me trying to play catch-up
because there was a time period
where trt was legal
you could legally get uh therapeutic
exemptions from doctors and fight still
in ufc
and other promotions like the
commission's allowed it
so uh when i was released by the ufc it
was kind of after that heartbreak i
talked about
i i was like why am i why am i making
less money
than these guys and they're cheating
like what am i what am i really gaining
by
by not doing what everybody else is so i
i rationalize myself back into it
but like i had the one fight i didn't
feel any better i could eat whatever i
wanted to and look
awesome that was nice but like my cardio
wasn't better nothing was better and
then the injection sites hurt so bad i
couldn't
i couldn't grapple at all i couldn't sit
on my ass like
i would we're using a harpoon to shoot
it in like a big mouth i think i was
using too big of a needle
okay really crazy um
yes so is that common you know with
fighters like do they use peds but just
at levels where it's like
looks natural at the time i think that
was
uh i think that was something that they
were doing a lot of
because i'd heard it from a couple
different places there was that fight or
war machine
he made a video that went viral where
he's talking about
literally how how you get a doctor to
prescribe you
tests in the first place and then how
you use it and things like that and
that's
uh i think a lot of guys were using that
approach for a little bit
yeah i mean it's not ideal like you like
you mentioned in one of the
conversations like it's not an ideal
substance for uh you know for a sport
where you have to make weight right
because i mean you're gonna put on water
actually yeah i don't know i couldn't
understand that unless you're like
putting on size to move up weight
classes it didn't make a lot of sense to
me to
to use something that's muscle building
yeah
yeah i mean it's not all muscle building
when you do put on some water weight too
for sure
yeah i think some of the some of the
ideology came from
what was going on with uh lance
armstrong
yeah stuff was coming out and there was
like
there's also the baseball stuff with uh
mark whatever his name was that
red-headed guy that was knocking
like every ball out of the park so there
was like there's different
strategies and things you were talking
about for use
so what about uh today like are you
still in trt
no so i haven't used since then and i
recently
did that let's get check thing online
and yeah i did a video on it like on my
channel
official john fitch but i'm at 567
now so i feel good i look good
uh my hair is still here i don't want to
i don't want to [ __ ] with my hair
so you would have started to lose your
hair by now if you had like the uh
predisposition to hair loss from
androgens
so like even your natural body's teeth
production will make it fall out
i'm just i don't i don't want to risk i
could
i could probably get shredded if i was
on it but uh
you probably wouldn't get as shredded as
what you are right now like you're
pretty ripped i've seen some of the
pictures you've posted on instagram and
you're pretty lean because i mean as
soon as you go on t
like what ends up happening is you put
on water weight you know like
immediately like probably in about eight
to ten weeks i probably put on about 10
pounds of weight and it wasn't all
muscle for sure
like i went from 198 to 208 like quickly
i've been uh yeah i've been eating i've
been trying to put on weight i'm trying
to get bigger
yeah i might get 220 right now i don't
want to get like
fat though so i'm trying to lift and get
well it's big for six foot tall if
you're 220 man
yeah it's a pretty it's a good size i
just uh i want to be a solid
220 and lose a little bit more of the i
got i pack it on the side i got like the
camel humps on the side love handles
yeah
that's what that's where i put on the
weight first well i mean you got the
core right you got to have the tight
cord to take all those hits
you built that way now
you